he is one of the most popular
of all time from the wrestling ring and
he is going to be
uh part taking place at barclay center
in brooklyn the wwe survivor series you
can watch it live this sunday on peacock
at eight eastern five pacific go to
peacock tv.com right now to sign up now
if you don't have it and uh if you don't
have it how have you been not watching
us right here on nbc sports on peacock
every single day roman reigns is here on
the rich island show how are you roman
reigns on the mercedes-benz vans hotline
how are you roman
i'm well rich thank you man thanks for
having me you got it you're in brooklyn
already sorry are you ready to go
uh no we have smackdown here in hartford
connecticut so i just got to uh hartford
okay
the work is never done my friend
your work is never done hartford to
brooklyn and then so on and so forth uh
how how are you um approaching this
event on sunday night sir what do you
got for me on that front for what
wrestling fans would like to know about
you
and this event on sunday night
well if you're a wrestling fan then
you've been following this journey that
i've been on for well over a year year
and a half or so and man i'm just trying
to stay consistent just trying to stay
in this uh this
this group that i'm in man i i've i've
been hitting on all cylinders for a
while now i've defended this universal
championship for
for
i think it's like at almost 450 days
where we're approaching
uh you know that that mid mark of 400
or so days so for me it's just to kind
of stick to my guns do what i do best
and go in in that ring and put on a
great performance
um and defend this universal
championship so hopefully another big
win another big dub for you roman reigns
so um how are you feeling uh your your
journey being um one involved with
leukemia that you've uh
had a a private battle with it then you
announced
that uh you were pulling out of events
due to covet concerns in 2020 how are
you right now as you and i are talking
i i feel great um you know and i think
anyone who's ever been through health
issues or health scares uh that becomes
ultimately
the number one priority and something i
think that you know a lot of humans
struggle with is is putting their health
uh
you know uh above and beyond
uh anything else because if we can't
take care of ourselves we can't take
care of anyone else so for me it was it
was it was a little bit of a journey
that really prioritized myself
you know especially someone you know as
a father and as a husband
um you're constantly thinking
of your loved ones but like i said you
know if
if you don't love yourself you can't
love anyone else and if you're not
healthy you can't really be concerned
with anyone else's health because the
name of the game is longevity and being
here as long as possible so i feel good
man i've done
a lot of things you know to really
improve my fitness and my health and
i've been on you know what we i guess
what a lot of people call that on this
journey and and it's been going well
it's a uh but it's definitely a marathon
you know it's not a sprint you gotta you
gotta stay consistent roman reigns here
on the rich eisen show how are you as a
defensive tackle man all acc your senior
year tell me about your game when you
were playing in the trenches at georgia
tech back in the day roman i
i wasn't bad man i you know like you
said all acc okay that was so when i
when i tried to break into the league
but that was my first run in uh with
into cmo and with the leukemia
uh so that definitely especially back in
that day in you know 2006 2007
uh it was a huge asterisk next to my
name we didn't have as many you know
occurrences with with young people
so it was just kind of the unknown the
great unknown
um but man i i started out at georgia
tech as a defensive end
i i got there at about 250 there was an
opening about midway through my freshman
year to uh play some defensive tackle
and i really just had pass rushing
skills i didn't you know i had no clue
how to play the run i didn't really have
any good hand work
you know i didn't understand you know
playing with my hands i just played with
speed um and i and i was pretty agile so
it was just a learning curve of putting
on that weight and getting big enough to
be able to you know be down in the
middle of the trenches and then also
just having the technique and having uh
you know the know-how of
playing with your hands and feet and you
know having violent hands but also
understanding the defense and and
knowing where to be at the right time
who's the best it was definitely a
journey who's the best quarterback you
ever sacked do you get a sack who's the
best one you sacked roman reigns oh man
did you take down you're back now um
yeah
what do you got
you take anybody down to take anybody
out
any point
man i i smacked brady quinn a couple
times back in the day i don't know if he
was the best he he was pretty he was
pretty good back in that day it might
that was my senior year
um i might have
i don't know if i ever sacked uh phillip
rivers but i i definitely have been in
this space i was only a freshman then so
i was just a young buck just a i was
just
just a young guy back then taking on nc
state you got you got in you got in
phillip rivers okay what's the hardest
hit you ever delivered to somebody on a
football field then roman reigns
on that one
probably uh what's it was a quarterback
for auburn
i think his name was brandon cox uh so
there's a there's a play where i i he
was throwing it and i i hit his arm and
the ball you know went up and one of our
linebackers picked it off and when i hit
that arm
my momentum kind of swung me up filled
behind him and as you know when an
interception happens
all the offense turns to run right they
try to get that angle to cut off that
defender with the ball
and he took probably two and a half
steps and turned around and i was right
there and i took his head off
it would not hold up in today's game
[Laughter]
roman reigns would have been called for
targeting he would have been called for
targeting
they might have took me out of two or
three games i i i
you you punished defenders for for doing
things like that it was a it was a heck
of a play
uh maybe a little bit on the dirtier end
of uh the physicality portion of hitting
a quarterback that way but i mean i just
and at this point i had learned to play
with my hands i i
had gained explosive hand movement and
learned how to uh you know really be
violent with the hands and
it wasn't just like a a regular block i
mean i shot my hands through his chest
and
you you look you'd think he was a
wrestler because he hit that ground so
fast and so hard it was uh
yeah they they they don't split into
that
we just showed a shot of you taking down
aaron brooks of virginia uh who uh he he
i think that's who we just saw if i'm
not mistaken right there it was not
brooks my bad but we just saw you take
somebody down a photograph of you on the
screen right there back in georgia tech
that so if you were if you were healthy
do you you think you'd have made the nfl
roman do you think 100
yeah i definitely do um
yeah you know i i was a very good
athlete you know and my numbers um you
know the the numbers i was able to put
you know up in my workouts and my you
know the measurables and the testing
they all translated to the field so i
was a very athletic and explosive you
know 300 pound defensive tackle uh i
could move and then i also was you know
pretty smart within the defensive scheme
you know i understood what my job was
and and you know playing with them at
defense and and my responsibilities
uh and then i also had some leadership
qualities so i do i do feel like
um i would have made a team and i would
have had a a pretty decent career do you
have an nfl team you root for roman
reigns do you have one
uh i'm a 49ers fan yeah my whole family
is no kidding okay
so
uh what do you think of what just
occurred i guess if you were checking
things out on monday night the current
state of the team roman what do you
think about that right now
so now
now i have to
now here here's the the terrible truth
is i'm not the best fan okay um it's all
good and i don't always follow up so i i
i don't even know what happened this
past year you're too busy man you're too
busy you're too locked in on your world
and that's the thing i do love about
folks like yourself in the wrestling
world is you you're you're a lead pipe
wielding professional you're locked in
what you got going on for your own self
so but who was your kid growing who was
your guy growing up then
back in the day then if you were as you
were a kid
at for the 49ers oh man i
yeah i mean steve young uh jerry rice we
had we had dion for a little bit um you
did
yeah this i mean ken norton jr uh ronnie
lot you saw me i mean that's how can you
not be a fan we can just the list goes
on and on right there's so many greats
that have
that have uh gone through the day so
it's we've been very fortunate you know
you see some teams
you know they don't have that much to to
be proud of within their organization
and their team uh and it's been many i
mean imagine being a browns fan i hope
you guys aren't brown
not too sick on you guys no that's
something you know i mean imagine that
you haven't had any much great success
no i know i'm a jedi i'm a jet fan roman
so uh you can just fill it up
i'm right there yes i am i feel like
you've just uh literally uh thrown me
out of the ring right now but it's all
good no worries uh i have my rich eisen
show social media grand maester
wrestling expert t.j jefferson who
always asks questions of people of your
stature when they come on the show tj
you got a question for roman reigns of
course i do okay hey what's up soleil
i just wanted to say right off the bat
good brother it's good talking to you um
first of all i have a message for joe if
i can
a buddy of mine calling peek i was
speaking to him yesterday and he had
some great things uh to say about you
and your time at georgia tech with
calvin johnson rich they all played on
the same team together so colin told me
to tell you hello
yeah kyle
tight end right yeah yep
yep
yeah i think i think he came from uh i
want to say alabama maybe yeah he
transferred tech he played for alabama
won a national title with them and then
uh he went to the falcons
and uh was in their camp uh for a year
or two and then uh now he's not doing
this he's a good player yeah he had a
lot of good stuff to say about you
um
now this question
is for the tribal chief if we can switch
into that character now
okay yeah
tribal chief what i like to do on the
show when we have wrestlers coming is i
like to kind of pitch my services to
them now i understand you have the
bloodline and you have your wise men and
you have your right hand man but i want
to let you know that i'm part of the la
manga
and i am willing to just give you my
services as i sit here on the rich eyes
and show a nationally
televised sports show right which
sees millions and millions of viewers
and i agree i look at this tribal chief
when you're out doing your thing you
could use me
as someone who can help spread the word
for the bloodline and so all i'm asking
is
if you'd be willing
to give someone like me who sits in
front of a microphone and who can't
spread the word
in the gospel of the bloodline a chance
to be a consiglier if you will a
a
you know subsidiary member of the
bloodline someone who maybe not sits at
the table but stands behind the table
and i'm just saying i'm just putting
that out there to you just to see what
the head of the table thinks and we have
a picture that i don't think you can see
but rich you and brockman
it's me in the ring with you and the
usos and the wise men and i feel like i
would be a perfect fit to help you in
any way that i can
okay so you're auditioning then
auditioning yes you know you're vying
for an opportunity here to uh yeah i
thought you had a question for me
but the question the question was that
it was just like are you looking for
someone
like me
who can help the bloodline in any way
possible that's all i'm saying
well we're we're always we're always
looking uh you know for people who are
trying to sing our praises and and you
know magnify
yes uh the scope of what we're doing so
i i dig what you're what you're trying
to do here yes but this is why i have a
special counsel and paul heyman so i'm
going to have to refer you to the wise i
understand that and he's he so that he
will be the loops and hoops that you're
going to have to jump through um but i i
think you're off to a good start here
you know that
i think the
the most important part is understanding
what you're stepping into and the
greatness that is going to be um you
know shining upon you and the island of
relevancy and all the responsibilities
that come with that i'm ready for that
we're always okay i mean that's first
step uh
you you have the okay
to send this resume now to to my jew to
the wise man
and well he already has one of those
right here roman yes
and that's all i was looking for rich
was a slow yes instead of a quick no
from the tribal chief now we can put the
process in order i'll talk to the wise
man paul heyman so there's now a
pecking order that you've gotten so
basically i understand roman he's gotten
passed through the first uh step of the
process is what you're saying
here
this was i i would say yes this was
this is the easiest step though
i accept that room and i appreciate that
because bobby lashley i tried it with
him in the her business he was kind of
like hey that's what you're saying
you're telling roman that he's second
oh no no not at all because this was
before the bloodline was created this
was before the bloodline was created yes
yes okay yes oh okay well you see what
happened with the herd business right
that that's not the uh that's that's not
the thing you wanted to be uh
we're holding strong
we're doing it big over here so
all right hey i appreciate you roman
reigns have a great uh performance
tonight um in in hartford and obviously
we are going to be seeing you on the wwe
survivor series on peacock on sunday
night thanks for the time let's do this
again soon appreciate it
absolutely absolutely rich thank you so
much right back at you that's roman
reigns at wwe roman reigns on twitter at
roman reigns on instagram right here on
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here